hey everybody it's mike from overflows
and welcome to this video on tick charts
and flow edges
you know as traders we have so many
different types of charts that we can
look at you know we have time-based
charts like minute-based charts you know
even 30-second charts and i know some
people that look at five second charts
you also got volume based charts
tick based charts
ranked charts hiking ashy charts you
know the list just goes on and on but
today really what i want to spend some
time on is talking about tick charts
so unlike time-based charts like one
minute charts or five-minute charts tick
charts are not constrained by time
a bar on a tick chart is based on a
particular number of trades that take
place
in that bar so for example if you have a
100 tick chart there has to be 100
trades regardless of the volume
okay so and that's how they differ from
volume based charts is because they
don't count the volume that would be a
volume based chart so if you're using
a volume based chart and you have a set
of a thousand it has to be a total of a
thousand contracts traded for one bar to
be formed whereas if you're using a
tick
chart
say of one thousand it has to be one 000
trades and the trade size can vary
so for example right just keep it simple
a 50 tick chart is going to be made up
of bars that each have 50 trades in them
a trade can be any volume trade can be
as small as one contract or it can be
more it could be three contracts 10
contracts 30 contracts
100 contracts obviously if you're using
a volume based chart and you're using
you know say
you know depending on the market
say you're using a uh you know say
you're trading wheat right and you've
got a 100
volume chart and 200 contracts trade
that would go over into two bars but on
a tick based chart
contracts trade that only counts as one
trade
okay
so you're looking at the number of
trades not the volume and not over a
period of time you're looking at it in
the bar
now you can choose how many ticks you
want to look at you can use say 25 ticks
you know 100 ticks 500 ticks it's up to
you
but keep in mind when trading
activity is busy you're going to see a
lot of bars form in a short period of
time so for example if you're using a
100 tick chart
in the e-minis
you're going to get bars like every
second basically so you're going to want
to space it out whereas if you're
looking at a 100 tick chart in a market
like say euro currency you know you
could take you know you'd be
you know one bar can form in you know 30
45 seconds you know maybe sometimes it
could be you know two minutes
and you know during slow periods of time
like for example you know after the
market reopens at 5 pm and
asia doesn't open up for another couple
hours
volume can be very light and you might
not get a lot of trades so you might not
see very many bars on a tick based chart
whereas if you're looking at a
minute-based chart you know every minute
is just going to tick tick you know new
bar new bar every minute whereas on a
tick based chart
it's got to have those trades for it to
um
form a bar
okay so
one of the benefits of tick charts well
i feel they allow you to get into moves
sooner and spot potential market terms
before they appear on more traditional
time-based charts because you know
you're looking at a time-based chart
you've got to wait for something to
develop because it's based on time
whereas
when you're looking at a tick based
chart you're really looking at trading
activity in the market
and one of the caveats though of tick
charts is
you're gonna find yourself much more
active in the markets meaning you're
probably gonna see
more trading opportunities and as a
result you're gonna take more trades
alright so it's tick charts in my
opinion is is not for everybody and
again you know that comes down to your
personal choice but you know i just want
you to understand some of the benefits
some of the caveats of using a tick
based chart now the flow edges indicator
which is our new indicator that we've
released
works great on
tick based charts i mean it works great
on all types of charts but you know i
want to spend some time talking about
tick based charts because you know
usually i do my presentations you know i
show things in minute based charts but
then you know people say can you show
this on a tick chart you know it can
show it on on this type of chart so i
want you to see how
this tool works on other types of charts
so let me show you let me uh pause this
here for a second and get up a chart
all right so this is a british pound
chart so
i'm going to show you it's the same
settings these are the default settings
for the flow edge indicator setting at 1
for the flow edge level swing strength
set to 0
and i'm using the trade
signal entry
meaning there's got to be follow through
order flow in the next bar or bars for
it to actually give you a signal that's
what these down triangles mean
for a cell and the up triangles for a
buy so this british pound 50 tick chart
all right set at one uh as the flow edge
level okay you see some nice movements
coming here all right nice move down a
nice move up you know you just sort of
take it back you know a little moves
down again you know this one here
probably would have stopped you out you
take a small loss but that's okay right
not every trade is going to be you know
this big beautiful trend here i mean
these are the trades we love to catch
but sometimes
due to market conditions
you're gonna get smaller moves or you're
gonna have you know a chance to take a
small loss or or break even on a trade
but the key is to you know sort of keep
your
powder dry right keep some bullets in
the gun so that when the big moves
happen like this you can participate in
them
right so this is british pound again
i'm just scrolling back here wait i just
want you to see these moves that occur
in the british pound on a 50 tick chart
right nice move up
again this is that
quiet period you know from the five
o'clock reopen right in here until this
is eight o'clock this is three hours
which you're not seeing very many bars
maybe about 20 bars just because the
market's quiet at that time whereas
opposed to here during the day
you know from you know this is what 9 30
to 9 o'clock you're seeing a lot more
bars in this 30 minute period than in
this three hour period
just because it's not a lot of trades
going through
let's go back another day here this is
the previous day this is the eighth
right nice move up nice move down
actually the move down started from way
up here in the 70s then you got a nice
move up here just prior to that all
right we've actually started in here
you know from the 50 area all the way up
into the 80s
scroll back a little bit more
again a little move here
again you know you don't just because
you see the bar colored right for
bullish flow edge you would color it
blue for bearish you would color it dark
red now again you can change those
colors simply by going to the indicator
setting and you just change you know the
bearish color so you don't want dark red
right
you know you can change it to magenta or
yellow or whatever color you want
but for now default is set at dark red
okay but you don't see the
triangle right on the cell here triangle
what you want to say mike why is there
not a triangle here because it's using
the trade entry signal which is this
setting
enable trade signal trade validity in
bars is 2 trade entry tick in bars is 2.
so it means you have to have follow
through order flow over the next two two
bars you can set it to one bar you can
set it to three bars four bars whatever
you want
but that's confirming
in the price action the signal that you
just got
okay so that's why you don't see
a blue triangle here or a red down
triangle here that's why you don't see a
red triangle here here you have the
follow through order flow
coming in this bar that's why it's
telling you to buy now
let's go back a little further again
this is where some earlier buys here on
the o6 area all the way up into the 20s
you know a little cell here a little by
there
but that was the previous day again
here's a nice
cell here a nice little cell here
um let's take a look at another contract
let's well since we're on currencies
take a look at the euro currency okay
euro currency in british pound
generally
generally not all the time you know have
sort of the same price movement so
british pound was
selling off a little bit today so expect
the same thing out of the euro currency
is trying to rally here a little
sell-off here a little rally here
nice sell-off here you know from the o4
area down into the 90s
you know nice little buy here these
cells didn't work out okay fine small
small losses i could live with that for
catching a nice move
nice move down nice move up
a little move up here
again just some small trades coming in
here
little move up nice beautiful move down
again this is a 50 tick chart in the
euro currency
again i don't want to talk about every
single move but i just want to show you
some potentials of some of these big
moves you know this move here from you
know the 94 area
all the way up into the teens
you know some late pies the day before
you know just a nice methodical move up
from 88
now this is 88 but this is 85 86
all the way up to double
it's oh nice moves here and there
a beautiful move here during the
european hours
okay so yeah
let's take a look at another
contract you know those two were
currencies but you know
sure you want to see how it looks on
some other markets here so let's take a
look at crude oil
now crude oil this is a 50 tick chart so
it might be a little bit quick might be
moving very fast
and again you don't have to use a 50
tick chart you can change it to 100 or
200 it really depends on your trading
style if you're very
short-term trader in and out a lot
you're going to lower the tick level
but again
yeah i'm just changing the chart so i'm
not changing the settings trying to
fine-tune it for these markets it's the
same setting for each of these markets
you can see it's just happening right
here right it's just running up right
you got your buy signals coming in down
here and shooting up you got a buy
signal down here
it's going up
again you know i don't want to talk
about every single little signal here i
just want to show you
you know i'm sure someone will say oh
you had this losing trade here
well really the signal you want to take
is the first one right
you're not going to if you get a sell
signal way up here you know on the 55
area then you get a sell signal 15
points lower at 40.
don't say well the 40 is a loser because
he really should have been long from up
there
again you can see how it's just starting
to turn right here
right it rallied up it's starting to
turn boom you get your cell signal just
like here's rallied up starting to turn
get your cell signal
now this is a 50 tick chart it's pretty
quick you can just see the time you know
8 55 26 28 30 31 i'll show you 36 et
cetera these bars are coming in hot and
heavy
so
on a tick based chart when a market is
got a lot of activity going on you're
going to get a lot of bars very quick
that doesn't mean you're going to get a
lot of signals very quick but it does
open that up for it a nice move here
that's why i talk about you know being
able to catch these moves as soon as
possible look at this
literally the bar right at the high is
giving you the sell signal right from
07.
look at that march down from 07 all the
way down to 60s
let me just go back some more you know a
beautiful buy right here you know from
the 55 area
all the way up to the 80s this is just
this morning this is just the last
couple of hours in in crude oil just to
give you an idea
all right i should just
not talk so much and just go through the
charts again you know 95 all the way up
into the 30s i mean you do have some
small trades here some small trades
there
but you really want to participate when
those big moves happen
let's take a look during
european hours in crude oil
okay four in the morning right here's a
nice sell coming in here around the 65
area all the way down into the 40s
and look at this move up you're going to
buy here but then you got maybe this one
would have stopped you out or you take a
small loss or you take a few ticks
then it came right back with this move
from 40s all the way up into the
80s
that
just during the european session
again
you see those moves
look at that move
move down
okay so let's just go back to the
previous day here so this is the eighth
okay this is
again same
chart setting i'm not changing it just
find some cherry pick chart i'm showing
you different markets the same chart
setting
and look at this you know it's catching
this whole move up here
all right imagine you're getting long
here from 55
all the way up into the 90s
you just seen these moves over and over
right as soon as it turns right here
telling you to get short it's not
telling you to get short when you break
out of this swing low here no it's time
to get short right now just as you hit
the swing high
where do you want to be getting short
right after you hit the swing high or
after you take out a swing low ideally
if you get out after you hit a swing
high
it's going to give you a better entry
and if you're wrong
it's going to
limit your loss because you're getting
short near a high as opposed to getting
short near a low
there's just there's a lot of trades you
know maybe a 50 tick chart on crude
isn't for everybody maybe some people
want to use a 100 tick chart or a 150 or
200 it really depends um you know on on
your trading style
you know if you're
sort of a cardiac trader you know
someone that wants to take a lot of
trades
then you're gonna use a lower tick
number okay but again you know you just
seen these these nice moves happen
over and over over the
in
different markets
right you want to participate them
as often as possible
okay so you're seeing some nice and nice
moves here
boom nice move down nice move up
go back to the european hours again
right as the market turns right here
right that's what you want to see is is
these moves happen as soon as possible
okay here you're getting short oh maybe
get long don't get short again write it
down okay cover get long up doesn't work
get short again 04 all the way down into
the 70s
okay again this is the overnight session
you're seeing nice moves up and you know
sometimes in these night sessions they
don't give you a lot of moves marcus
does move though
and you know you're only talking about a
20-point move here 20-point move there
but it's giving you that signal as soon
as that swing low has been made or as
soon as that swing high has been made
right and that's what you want to see as
a trader right you want to be getting
into these moves literally as soon as
they're happening
you know swing high boom get short swing
high boom get short
good you know you like ride these moves
for as much as it can you know here
here a little back and forth okay
uh let's take a look at another market
you know a market that's sort of
near and dear to me is the wheat market
50 tick chart
this is this morning look at this move
you know 771 all the way down in the 60s
all right as soon as that's high has
been made here
giving you a short signal
now again you know wheat doesn't trade
as much as crude oil this is just the
day here basically
you know from there to there
but look at that
you're able to scalp this market
move here move up here move down here
move down here
back up back down
move up move down move up
move down
so
let's take a look at another market
uh look at mini dao okay because yeah
this is interesting because i'm on a 50
tick chart okay so there's
let's talk a little bit about the
settings
i don't make this too much about the
settings today but this is again the
default setting that comes with the
indicator set to one and zero all right
so you can see here right it looks like
there's a lot of signals uh god you know
i can't trade this mic because
look at this from 926 right here
basically to here you've got like eight
bars okay you got a lot of signals
and again you know some people you know
they want to see
those signals now a way you can clean it
up is you set the strength
higher
see mike that's too many signals well
then you set the flow
edge level to a higher number
three which means it's a stronger one
okay and now you're seeing you know the
buy here you're not seeing so many
signals right getting short in here
right getting short from here
getting long from down here
okay little
stutter step here
a little move here then boom just get
you back
going in that direction gets you back up
in this direction
so that's one way you can do it another
way is is the swing filters
if you have it at one you could
you know you could change the swing
filter to one
or swing strength rather
to one
so one and one
again it cleans it up a bit you're
seeing this nice buy at the low here
now you're not getting the cell here
getting the cell here so imagine you're
buying it in here around 20
15 to 20. your first sell signal is up
here at 80.
it's a 60-point move
right you'll catch this sharp move down
followed by this sharp move up
getting short at 60
56 cover it at 16 right back up
to where you got short at right nice
move up here nice move up there
so there's many different ways that you
can use
tick charts right but you know flow
edges in my opinion is a great tool for
using with tick charts
in the future i'll be making a video you
know using time-based charts and
volume-based charts that you can compare
but you know if you're not already using
tick based charts you might want to
throw one up on your on your monitor
right monitors now are very inexpensive
if you have you know i see these people
saying oh you know you don't need many
monitors to trade successfully you know
you don't but there's no harm in adding
another one just to keep an eye on
something in the market
right no but you know
i hate these people that say no you have
to trade this way no you have to trade
that way no you trade the way that
benefits you the most right so whether
you're using one monitor two monitors
three monitors it's your personal
decision
okay it's like this whole hoo-ha with
the vaccine
you know some people
don't want the vaccine
other people want to have the vaccine i
have the vaccine i'm fine with it but
there's other people you know i respect
their choice if they don't want to get
the vaccine fine
you know you don't have to trade with
one monitor you don't have to trade with
two monitors i'm just saying you know if
you
are trading
there's no harm in adding an additional
chart
to look at
right because you know you might find
that you start to move away from you
know your time-based chart into
something that is more conducive to how
you want to trade so anyway thanks for
watching this video and again you know
if you're interested in getting flow
edges
go to www flow
or just click on click on the link below
so thank you and bye